und zwar möchte ich nämlich heute über
den europäischen geist sprechen meine
these heute abend ist der europäische
geist lebt bilder von demonstrationen
die uns den atem raubt prag berlin oder
madrid hunderttausende ziehen auf die
straße und beweisen dass putins kriegt
die macht der freiheit und demokratie
niemals besiegen wird auch die große
spendenbereitschaft
hilfsorganisation berührt ein besonders
inspirierend sind für mich aber auch die
menschen die eigenständige fahrten
organisieren um selbst hilfsgüter an die
grenze zu fahren oder die bürger die
sich sogar in listen eintragen um
flüchtlinge bei sich aufzunehmen der
europäische geist brennt lichterloh die
eu stellt sich auf millionen flüchtlinge
aus der ukraine ein um ihn schnell und
unbürokratisch helfen zu können will die
eu einem massenzustrom richtlinie aus
dem jahr 2001 aktivieren ich finde es
gut ist in allen mitgliedstaaten das
gleiche verfahren gelten soll und die
flüchtlinge bis zu drei jahre schutz der
eu erhalten
wir wissen nicht genau was sich
präsident putin gedacht hat bei dem
angriff auf die ukraine aber sollte er
sich gedacht haben wir europäer die
regeln sie ein paar tage auf dann regen
sie sich auch wieder ab und dann kommt
business as usual ein ganz großer irrtum
und das wird auch weit über einen
möglichen waffenstillstand hinaus die
europäer eher zusammenschweißen und wenn
er zweitens geglaubt hat dass europa sie
in dieser frage auseinander dividieren
lässt weit gefehlt das gilt sowohl
gesellschaftspolitisch als auch zwischen
den 27 eu staaten auch in der
flüchtlingspolitik selten war einigkeit
so groß inklusive polen und ungarn die
jahr 2015 216 eine ganz andere haltung
in dieser frage eingenommen haben es
selbst in der flüchtlingskrise damals
wurde die eu massen zustroms richtlinie
so heißt die tatsächlich nicht aktiviert
aber
jetzt das gibt den menschen sicherheit
über drei monate hinaus drei monate
können sie ihr visafrei einreisen
aber dann in einem schnellen
unbürokratischen verfahren
sie werden wohl jeden fall zum weit
überwiegenden teil in den nachbarländern
bleiben also in rumänien tschechien
slowakei ungarn oder eben in polen
ja das glaube ich lena ist beeindruckend
wir haben zu beginn der sendung auch
genau schon darüber gesprochen das ist
europa wie man sich nicht hätte besser
eigentlich vorstellen können und ich
glaube der punkt den sie machen also
putin hat eigentlich das gegenteil
dessen erreicht was er über jahre ja
immer wieder versucht hat zum teil auch
hinbekommen hat nämlich
europa sei es die eu oder sei es auch
die nato partner zu spalten das ganze
thema 9 zu 2 ist ja das prominenteste um
ein keil beispielsweise zwischen
osteuropäer und auch westeuropäer zu
treiben nun mal so aber es gab auch
andere die stabilisierung des machen
haben gekippt alles hier stellt genau
aber da gibt es jetzt ein echter
einigkeit und da hat die bundesregierung
ganz spät reagiert aber sie hat dann
irgendwann auch reagiert gab dabei die
stabilisierungsversuche
in den vergangenen jahren immer wieder
dem ein oder anderen land ja auch in
deutschland aus dem kreml gesteuert und
es ging immer darum eigentlich europa
als schwachen continuo den einmal
stellen einen schalter ganz kurz vor ich
musste mich verabschieden wir müssen
jetzt tatsächlich in diesem moment
einmal für zur sicherheit in den keller
gehen ist sozusagen die zweite
sicherheitskette ausgelöst worden und
deswegen muss ich mich verabschieden
bedanke mich für die diskussion zumal
ich kann eine million mitglieder nicht
verleihen ich würde so gerne tun für
guten journalismus für mut und für das
saftig auch vielen dank wichtiger ist
dass die ukraine überlebt herzlichen
dankeschön gesagt ich auf paul
das ist immer ein sehr merkwürdiges
gefühl vor allem wenn es bei einem
kollegen aus dem haus natürlich auch ist
wenn man darüber spricht was man noch
tun kann außer in die pause großartigen
journalismus machen das kann ja jetzt
nicht jeder tun was gibt es denn noch
verpasst was man jetzt gerade tun kann
als bürger es ist wichtig dass man neben
den gästen im team sie mal so viel
lokalpatriotismus wird sein dass der
rosenmontag um funktioniert ja zwei es
werden bilder ja von 1000 dem antrag der
und blau gelb eine gewaltige
friedensdemonstration das war ein ganz
eindrucksvolle und das friedlich bei
aller ernsthaftigkeit
es war toll ganz unterschiedliche
gruppen die da zusammengekommen sind
dass das eine aber diese ganz praktische
hilfe mit lebensmitteln mit anderen
gütern die vor ort gebraucht werden das
jetzt zu organisieren und wir sagen ja
so oft ja so ellbogengesellschaft und so
das war im aartal auch anders er eine
enorme hilfsbereitschaft und jetzt
wieder eine enorme hilfsbereitschaft das
bestätigt sie etwas was mein pastor
immer gesagt hat ist die not groß ist
die kirche voll und wenn die not am
größten ist dann kommen die besten
eigenschaften von uns menschen zum
vorschein und hier eben nicht für
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger sondern für
die europäischen mitbürger in der
ukraine
ich hab von freunden von
geschäftspartnern so viele angebote
bekommen ich habe ein zimmer sagte
scheidt wenn deine freunde eine
unterkunft benötigen was kann ich tun
ein freund von mir ist an die grenze
gefahren von warschau an die ukrainische
grenze versorgt dort seit tagen rund um
die uhr die flüchtlinge das einzige wo
es noch den sächlichen bisschen dann
mangelt ist die versorgung auf der
ukrainischen seite wo man ja so lange im
stau stehen musste das soll jetzt ein
bisschen besser sein aber auch ich
bekomme das aus dem engsten kreis mit
wie groß einfach diese auch dieses
mitgefühl ist für unsere mit europäer ja
die menschen in der ukraine sind ja
europäer und wollen auch europäer sein
und wollen den europäischen weg gehen
und das habe ich so nicht gesehen auch
selbst nicht jemand der die
flüchtlingskrise 2015 ohne skepsis
gesehen hat im gegenteil aber hier ist
doch eine ganz andere stimmung warum ist
jetzt eine ganz andere stimmung jan und
auch ein ganz anderer einstellung dazu
also wenn ich das einmal noch sagen darf
dass sich ein kollege aus einer
laufenden sendung in einem
luftschutzbunker verabschieden muss
ich glaube das zeigt zum einen die
dramatik in der sich dieser kontinent
befindet
die
da muss man sagen extrem besondere
situation der wir uns befinden dass es
einfach wieder ein aggressor gibt der
gar nicht so weit von uns entfernt sitzt
und das paul der zwei flugstunden von
hier entfernt ist von berlin aus jetzt
ein luftschutzbunker sitzt das muss man
sich vorstellen dass wir es ungefähr so
als wenn ich jetzt von hier nach
mallorca fliegen würde das sind ja
ungefähr die abstände und das ist finde
ich auch wirklich aller schlimmste art
und weise bedrücken da kann man nur
beten dass nicht nur unsere kollegen
aber alle menschen in der ukraine der
auch jetzt heil und in kiew diesen
angriff dann heil überstehen und ich
glaube genau diese situation ist es auch
weil das auch so nah ist bei uns dass
man sagt wie kann es eigentlich sein es
könnte ja sogar uns treffen wie kann es
eigentlich sein dass in diesem
jahrhundert nach dem leid was dieser
kontinent gesehen hat sich jemand
hinstellt und einfach sagt weil es mir
passt und weil ich lust drauf habe und
einfachen ego-shooter bin greif ich
einfach mit waffengewalt ein anderes
land an und knallt die menschen ab und
lasst sie töten das ist das macht ein
fassungslos und ich glaube genau das ist
das gefühl auf der andasa dass menschen
sagen du nicht du schwein ich sag jetzt
mal du nicht nicht mit uns
selbst soldaten der bundeswehr in
uniformen werden jetzt in deutschland
anders wahrgenommen hat erzählen mir
dass soldaten die ich gerne wo es über
jahre alt war
progressiver und gebildeter mann sich
wehrte so ein bisschen mindestens
belächelt über soldaten her zu ziehen
jetzt der ganz andere situation und auch
deshalb glaube ich die politischen
umbrüche im deutschen bundestag die
bundeswehr wird plötzlich ganz anders
wahrgenommen dann drehen sie mir nicht
besser sich sowieso
therapie dem mädchen schon die worte
unterbreche ich möchte aber einmal nach
auf ein herz für kinder aufmerksam
machen da können sie nämlich hin spenden
wir sie mich kurz vorm sendungs ende
bild hat heute schon also ein herz für
kinder deutschen eine million gespendet
und sie können auch mitwirken hier sehen
sie auch mal eingeblendet wo man spenden
kann denn das ist uns heute auch noch
mal eine große herz
helfen sie uns spenden sie auch für ein
herz für kinder das ist bei den menschen
vor ort besser geht kann man gar nicht
sagen aber dass sie dort unterstützt
werden vielen herzlichen dank und
schönen abend noch